on continue d'en parler avec nous on
dirait que l'écrivain claude janvier
claude janvier bonjour merci d'être avec
nous alors vous l'avez certainement vu
on vient de le voir finalement les
participants au convoi de la liberté ont
réussi à rentrer dans paris
bravo bravo à eux
c'est très impressionnant et ça c'est
vraiment très courageuse vraiment bravo
à tous les partis parce qu'on veut la
liberté d'ailleurs je pense que ce
convoi de la liberté peuvent être plus
flatté
de policiers de gendarmes qu'ils soient
mobilisés parce que c'est 200 policiers
gendarmes plus des blindés gendarmerie
effectivement celle du gène c'est du
jamais vu depuis depuis dix suit depuis
le gilet jaune on le dispositif des
amendes est vraiment lourd
c'est vrai que ils risquent
4500 euros d'amendé pour cent contre 6 à
blocage les organisateurs risque 7500
euros d'amendé on voit de prison on voit
vraiment qu'il ya une répression
dommage c'est que aussi bien au canada
qu'en france en fait il n'y a pas de
dialogue possible c'est à dire peu dès
que le peuple veut faire entendre une
des raisons les himbas contre toute
cette dictature sanitaire cette espèce
de terrorisme virale il n'y a pas de
dialogue puis si peu plus d'eau au
canada ne veut absolument pas bien le
lait et le gouvernement de monsieur mac
pro ne veut pas dialoguer non plus donc
c'est vraiment tout de suite la force
qui est employé et ça c'est dommageable
vers l'europe ce qui veut dire qu'il n'y
a aucun dialogue aujourd'hui entre les
pouvoirs publics que le peuple et ça
franchement ça c'est vraiment à bannir
alors vous parlez des manuels map - le
président qui vont être embêtés
j'imagine en gérer une telle crise à
quelques mois de la présidentielle ce
n'est pas forcément évident non moi
c'est pas évident mais de plus son c il
a signé comme comme on peut dire il a
été élu il assume mais il a su vraiment
mal parce qu il refuse le dialogue il
refuse d'entendre il refuse de se plier
à quoi que ce soit faut pas oublier la
répression sanglante et gilet jaune moi
j'ai pas oublier vous savez vingt-sept
personnes ont perdu un oeil à cette
époque il ya eu plus de 150 blessés
graves ni lui je sais pas combien de
blessés ça a été vraiment une répression
sanglante pas de dialogue sous des
prétextes fallacieux parce qu'en fait
les manifestations jamais été violente
il y a eu des black blocs qui ont
infiltré les manifestations mais sa
clope d'habitude et ce sont eux les
casseurs et non pas le reste du peuple
et donc là on aime on est aussi dans des
manifestations violentes il n'y a
toujours pas de dialogue en revanche il
ya les brigades de crs qui sont là où
problème près prêts effectivement à
appliquer les ordres à la lettre et est
même trop un peu trop zélé parce que
j'ai eu plus de 300 pb qui ont été
distribués ce matin il ya aussi une
grosse censure au site facebook parce
qu'apparemment le compte les pompes des
organisateurs des trois cent mille
adhérents auraient été fermés par
facebook on a vraiment aussi une censure
dégâts femme ça c'est dramatique aussi
donc avoué didier emmanuel macron qui
refuse le dialogue va peut-être parce
qu'il pensait que les forces de sécurité
allaient pouvoir empêcher ce convoi de
la liberté d'entrer à paris finalement
on le voit un des images en direct le
combat de la liberté et dans paris est
ce qu emmanuel macron va être contraint
de changer de fusil d'épaulé
on pourrait l'espérer maintenant est-ce
qu'il va le faire j'en doute boyer où il
y avait une façon simple à le convoi de
la liberté mais ils ne se sont jamais
cachés donc ils allaient arriver donc
pourquoi avoir ordonné aux forces de
l'ordre de bloquer la capitale de
bloquer une perry fin alors qu'en fait
il suffisait de laisser passer le convoi
de la liberté est il autorisé la
manifestation on voit bien qu'ils aient
tout est organisé pour répond pour qu'il
n'y ait aucun dialogue possible
donc maintenant c'est à lui c'est à lui
de vouloir ouvrir le dialogue alors
est-ce qu'il va entendre
on appelle nos appels ça c'est moins sûr
parce que jusqu'ici il a toujours refusé
le dialogue donc la balle est dans son
camp parce que là je pense que le
mouvement populaire le mouvement d'un
ras-le-bol comme je les ai dit tout à
l'heure de cette dictature sanitaires
légers pas peur des mots de ce
terrorisme virales ne va pas s'arrêter
parce que franchement hollande a marre
on en a marre des décisions stupides moi
je repense un peu à la décision du
ministre castex faux bond alors boire
son café debout c'est mortel mais le
boire à six as et inoffensif parce que
le virus y fit ils circulent en l'air
n'y circule pas ici mais attendez on est
dans du délire total imposé un passant
en plus un pass vaccinale décennies
liberticide ça ne sert strictement à
rien en plus les gens qui sentent qu'ils
peuvent actionner sont tout aussi
possible d'être contaminés et sont aussi
contaminants alors à quoi ça sert un
moment donné faut peut-être arrêter
arrêtez de vouloir pousser des vaccins
qui enfin des mac sein des liquides
expérimentaux qui ont été uniquement
poussé par des laboratoires en plus
américains ou anglo saxons le plus
souvent et qui sont comme chacal c'est
d'aider des liquides expérimentaux arn
messagers curieux d'ailleurs que les
vaccins outre vous parliez de l'ukraine
tout à l'heure c'est curieux quand même
que le streak qui est un vaccin élaboré
par la russie qui apparemment a été peu
d'effets secondaires ne n'arrive pas à
franchir l'europe ah oui si on est
justement vous parlez des restrictions
sanitaires c'est l'objet ans est un des
objets de ces revendications il n'y a
pas que ça également les manifestants
dénonçaient cette baisse du pouvoir
d'achat des français et l'inflation qui
est énorme en ce moment ben oui
malheureusement encore vous prenez à
l'essence aujourd'hui c'est un 60 à 68
ans 75 mm 1,89 à peine 1 dans certaines
stations pardon il ya une inflation
patente que l'on peut vérifier tous les
jours sur des produits de première d'ici
cité sur des produits alimentaires et il
ya une rousse sans arrêt et ça ne
s'arrête pas il ya une inflation elle
est nette alors moi ce que je trouve
étrange aussi c'est que les syndicats
routiers et là je vais lancer peut-être
un petit peu un appel c'est que les
chèques les syndicats des transports
routiers on ne les entend plus il ya
quelques décennies ils étaient prompts à
bloquer tout le pays aujourd'hui il ne
se passe plus rien alors la grande
question est qu'est-ce qui se passe ils
ont donc pas c'est un peu étrange je
pense que le prix du gasoil est très
haut et il ya toujours aucune
revendication déjà des syndicats de
chauffeurs routiers là aussi on peut se
poser les clis toi donc le 2 janvier
vous rappelle que vous êtes écrivain
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions